carolina serrano congressional candidate
joining us here to talk on politics now
about uh
running for congressional district four
thank you again for joining us
appreciate it
thank you for having me uh let's just
start quite simply with uh
what do you believe that you could bring
to uh cd4 if you're
elected so i think that what we're kind
of lacking right now
is some fresh energy and i think people
who
are more connected to the voters so i
want to say for cd4 and specifically in
vegas
a lot of the workers are hospitality
workers they work on the strip service
industry and that's been my background
for almost 20 years
i was a culinary union member and i
think that having that connection with
the voters will be
good for them because you know sometimes
it's great to have small business owners
running but
not everybody's a small business owner
so i think somebody who connects with
them in that sense
what is in your view the disconnect with
the incumbent uh congressman stephen
horsford
well i think that he champions a lot of
policies that don't benefit
working middle class and so stephen
horstworth i don't think that has ever
worked on the strip knows what it's like
to clock in and out
to um sacrifice weekends and holidays
and you know not know what's next after
the service industry
or hospitality it's 24 7 in the city so
now we'll get to what you would like to
do in terms of sort of making what
you're suggesting
a reality in a second here but first
let's talk about just getting your
campaign off the ground here
financial support is so important uh
you've been supported
notably you've gotten some donations
already from steve wynn
how did that happen um and obviously
given mr winn's recent
history did you have any hesitation
about taking his donations
i didn't because i worked for women
encore for almost eight years
and i would say in my 13 years in the
service industry those eight years were
the best ones
and so having his support means a lot i
have a lot of respect for
what his vision and how he's changed las
vegas so i'm happy to have it
okay in terms of just other kinds of
fundraising other kinds of support in
the community what what else are you uh
have you already achieved what are you
still trying to garner
when you're talking to the folks in the
in cd4
as far as just in terms of money i mean
that's the bottom line here you're
running right now sam peters is the
other republican running he's run before
he's got a lot of more money than you do
right now
to get the policies that you're talking
about into place
that is a crucial aspect of that so what
efforts are you making right now to try
and
get to those fundraisers get to those
supporters to turn what you want to do
into something that you can do
well i think you know i think having the
grassroots support is good
so having the grassroots know me having
their support maybe getting their
donations and then
all around i think that people are ready
for
some fresh energy and some fresh change
and i think that that speaks a lot to
voters donors and uh the fact that you
know
i'm hispanic and i think that i have a
really good message with that community
as well
so i can kind of bridge the gap between
all different
types so you you just discussed about
your connection with folks who work in
the service industry in las vegas we've
been through such a difficult time with
the pandemic
and the resorts were shut down for such
a long time what do they need in your
opinion what do they need to get back on
their feet to find employment or if
they're already employed
how to get back on even terms i think
that they need other options besides the
service industry
like i said i mean it's great for a a
bit of time
but it doesn't have that longevity that
you need in order for you to be able to
build a home have a family have you know
create wealth i would say so i think
that there's just other options outside
the
service industry would be good for them
so so from a policy standpoint then what
what is that
what does that look like in terms of
getting them out of the cycle of the
service industry
so i would say you know hospitality is
great if if you want to stay in it but i
would say
i would love to see policies that bring
back manufacturing to
the us right because we don't really
produce much here in the u.s
and i think you know one of the
industries that i would love to see come
down here would be the fashion industry
i think it would be such a great place
to have that
industry here in vegas where vegas is
kind of this fancy glitzy
place you know um one of the other
issues in congressional district four
it's an enormous district stretching you
know well north into esmeralda county
rural lands and we saw just you know how
long ago was it was the issue with
the bundy ranch federal land protections
is a big issue in your district
what is your feeling on the idea of
protections of federal lands and how do
you think
the federal government should move
forward legislatively
to try and either protect or to open up
more lands for more development or solar
plants or whatever the case may be
i think there's a fine balance i think
that i want to say the numbers
we only develop on about 30 percent of
land in in the us
i love wildlife obviously i want a
protection for that to stay in place but
i think there's definitely a balance
between
what's good for the residents and humans
as well as
you know preserving wildlife and and
conserving that
uh do you i don't know if you can dig
back into history here a little bit
it's but the way the situation up in
bunkerville was handled years ago
are you satisfied with the way that was
that went down the way that was handled
those protections were
were utilized i'll have to be honest i
would have to
look more into it to give you a firm
stance on it
one of the things that you mentioned
during your um your
campaign video your announcement you
spoke a lot about immigration
and bill to finishing the wall why is
that such an important issue
why do you think the wall needs to be in
your words finished well i think it's
always been an important issue i mean i
voted democrat and
before they were always about protecting
the border and protecting the country i
think
everybody knows that if you have an open
border then you really aren't protecting
the citizens of this country right it
just becomes
chaotic so the border wall is important
and then there also needs to be a total
immigration overhaul because also the
people who are coming here to
have a better life for themselves
they're not benefiting from an open
border either because
each time a new crop comes in that's
lower wages for
for big business and not beneficial to
the people who are trying to make it
when you say open border the border
isn't necessarily open obviously there
are
there it's not is open a fair way to
describe our borders right now
yeah because i mean if you go down to
like texas i love road tripping so i've
been down to texas
arizona it's vast lands and you see
people
crossing through where there is in a
border there's no
barrier right and so yeah i mean
dhs we know is overwhelmed and so i
would say that they're releasing a lot
of people into the country
and they have no date to show up most
people don't show up to the dates
so it's a problem when you were talking
about your own
uh connection in cd4
and i'm wondering how immigration policy
if you were elected into congress
would translate into the people you
serve in congressional district four how
would
changing immigration uh reworking how
the u.s policy is how would that affect
the folks that you serve and the people
that work in las vegas
well i would say that it affects
everybody right because
our wages don't go up because we
constantly have an inflow of people who
are willing to work for lower wages
and so everybody across the board no
matter your status i think that
you should need you should demand or
want
a better immigration system for
everybody because it's not fair to
anybody right now it's not fair american
taxpayers it's not fair to the people
who are coming in
and not getting paid a fair wage right
you're running as a republican obviously
you were on the
you helped support former president
trump in his re-election campaign
uh how much of that experience would you
bring into
a primary and a general election
campaign how much do you lean on
the former president do you still
support him do you think he should still
be president
well obviously i worked on his campaign
it was a great experience so yes i
support the president
um i think that that experience was one
of the best experiences and i would say
that everyone should
knock doors in their community because
you find out that you have a lot more in
common
with your neighbor than you think and so
i think there's a lot more in common
between
people who are trump supporters and
people who are bernie supporters and you
could
bring them together on certain issues
i guess what i'm getting at is do you do
you think he actually won
do you do you believe that the election
was fair and do you
think that some of these election
reforms that are being discussed not
only in nevada but nationwide
uh should be should be brought into
place definitely think that there needs
to be more transparency because i did
work
the election and i also helped after
november 3rd with the legal team
and my brother was a victim of a fraud
he went to go vote in person but his
ballot
somebody received a ballot at his old
address it was turned in and so his vote
was provisional never counted
so i would say that yes i would
absolutely love to see more transparency
that way
people can be confident when they vote
because i think that's the most
important thing
okay just getting again just to
put a period on this are you
convinced in the election results
um no i think that there needs to be
more transparency
okay just from from my own being on the
ground and
talking to voters and seeing what i saw
especially here in nevada
seeing what i saw afterwards no
okay um final question
you as i mentioned you talked a lot
about in your campaign
video issues of immigration but you also
mentioned issues of law enforcement
and you referencing defunding the police
from a law enforcement standpoint what
would you like to bring into place
in congress to support law enforcement
and what do you think is being done
in your opinion to get in the way of
their efforts
well i think um
so i think i would say here i don't know
if you guys still do it here but the
coffee
coffee with the sheriff or something
like that i think it's good to highlight
kind of bridge the gap between law
enforcement and the community
and have the community see them as
people too right
i would think defending doesn't work i
would say that they might need a little
bit more funding to get better training
if that's
what we're aiming for but to take
policing out of communities that need it
no i wouldn't say that just finally
you're talking about money towards law
enforcement
let's get back to something i should
have asked earlier there's
infrastructure measures being discussed
in congress right now we know about the
billions of dollars more than that that
have been thrown at trying to recover
from the pandemic
is is that the right way to get this
country out of the pandemic
by putting money towards whether it's
staying in their homes whether it's
business small business recovery
should the us be spending more money to
recover from the pandemic um
that's a tough question to answer it
might be it might be too long but
the monetary policy that we have in
place in the country that's been in
place for decades
doesn't help so right now i mean we're
a debtor nation we have a huge amount of
debt right and to keep on
taking money essentially on the backs of
the workers and people who aren't even
born yet i don't think that that's
good monetary policy or good fiscal
responsibility
for anybody so it's tough so then what's
the way to get out of the pandemic if
it's not to put money towards
economic recovery towards keeping people
in their homes
towards small business recovery loans
what is the way to get out of uh
something so devastating as a pandemic
well i would say you know
let people go back to work i would i
mean i like the infrastructure i do
but like i said there needs to be a
change
in the monetary policy that's been in
place for decades and so
that needs to be talked about and i
think that that's something that nobody
talks about when you say monetary policy
you mean just
spending money that you don't have so
modern monetary theory of policy right
which is kind of you you borrow and then
you spend and that's why
we have americans who can't pay for a
400
emergency right because if you put your
money in a bank today it loses its
purchasing power
because you know because of our fiscal
policy right
so i think it's getting to a place where
um
we encourage savings and that way people
are more prepared for something like
this
all right good luck in your campaign
thank you for coming by appreciate it i
appreciate it thank you john